welcome back to new rock stars loki
episode 5 brought us closer to the real
big bad behind the tva but not
before throwing us a bunch of easter
eggs backstabbing loki's
in a variant eating mega cloud at us
first how is this wild show going to end
that's what i ask this is rogue theory
the show where we pitched the wildest
theories for the shows and movies that
we love
my name is mt and going rogue with me
today is comedian and writer
jessica clemens what's going on jess an
actor and host of whitney vision whitney
van landing
hello whitney hi how are you i'm just
really psyched about alligator loki
that's where i'm at
today right dude he took that man's
whole arm off
i'm all about it dude think about it i
have a serious theory about that that i
will talk about later
and of course entertainer and host from
fandango
hail anonymous what's going on hey i
mean wait hold on
there we go yeah oh my god everybody
hey hey how's it going thanks for having
me on of course kale of course
we need all three of you guys to go
rogue on this latest episode of loki
because
it's kind of crazy we have the loki's
all in limbo or
i'm sorry the void and they're all
trying to escape the void by attacking
eliath
the uh big mega cloud that likes to eat
things from other realities with loki
and silvie
now headed to this mysterious castle at
the end of time at the end of the
episode
how the hell is this crazy journey with
all these gods of mischief
going to wrap up i just want audio of me
saying
it's king the conqueror just so that
when it isn't
when he's not in there that i can be
called out for it
so guys here's what i think i think it's
king the conqueror
in that in that castle okay but
seriously though i think it's another
loki
you think it's another location i think
it's another loki i think okay
i think that the ultimate battle that he
has to do
is one last time fight himself and
like show that he's overcome every
single thing that he's
said about himself because what if you
recall loki
his big thing is he wants to like he
wants to be king he wants to rule over
all
and this loki is trying to preserve
whatever timeline keeps everyone else
from
being able to stop him from doing that
and so i think the final
boss is going to be loki but that king
the conqueror is going to be involved in
some way because kang has a lot of
uh ability he has time manipulation
and he has access to technology it'll be
really fun to see another loki again
right more loki's monkeys all over the
world just
sprinkles this last episode had
not enough loki's for me you know we had
that whole location but i was like you
know what we could have like
two or three times more than this
well but no i really like that idea
because like i like you said about like
having that last um like final boss i
should say
um be like another loki would be like
sort of
like this final pin to the the tale of
like loki overcoming himself and like
he's just the whole show is about
himself so like i do like that
as a storytelling element it's it's it's
like
it's like a nice wrap up to it as like a
marvel
fan sort of thing i think a lot of
people are gonna be mad it's not like
mephisto or something you know so
or what if it's like one of what if it's
like one of the weird loki's
you know what i mean like because we
already saw the frog thor so what if
it's like a weird
a weird loki i'm thinking just well how
weird are we talking kayla how weird
beta ray bill weird
it's kind of like okay that's what i'm
thinking
just give me another
let's get all the in let's get all the
zoo full of loki's just seriously
here's my here's my alternate uh theory
about president loki
after alligator loki takes his hand
because this is disney what if that loki
turns into captain hook
moves to the the island with all the
lost boys
and now like this loki was db cooper
that loki is now captain hook oh my god
are we doing like a dark peter pan
cinematic universe
oh a hundred percent yeah it could work
considering that the actual
land that they're in could actually be
like a neverland type scenario dude hook
is going to be so hot they would make
hooks so sexy oh dude tom hiddleston
hook would be great i'm into it he
already has a missing hand
what more does he need he just needs a
hook that's all that's all it's so easy
to get
prop department done exactly you could
just take one of his horn hooks
[Applause]
[Laughter]
what do you think jess what do you got
i agree but i also disagree it's really
hard because
if anything's unraveling it's just
everyone's theories it seems like we've
been like
jumping it's so much of a conclusion
that the writers are like no it's the
most basic form one plus one equals two
and i'm like no
it could equal something else so i'm
just like
i wanna believe because we haven't seen
like the king loki we haven't seen him
from the trailers right
so i was like oh king loki's gonna be
behind there and it's gonna have to be a
battle between the two
loki's right but then i was like you
know what marvel likes to do they like
to put flashbacks and freaking
trailers so i think that king loki's not
gonna actually be there it could be kang
or it could be rand slayer from a
different timeline branch
that are waiting there foreman's like if
you let us to keep doing this look at
the timeline you could be
you could be king of asgard you could be
king of this this is what you could be
so i don't think i i think the most
writer 101 trick is to make it a
freaking loki which i want it to be
but the rogue theory in me is like it
it's got to be someone else and i really
want it to be kang
but i don't think we're gonna see kang i
actually don't think we're gonna kiss
you
i have a theory that might actually fit
with that um just to add on to that
because
i also i also do think that it's it's
most likely gonna be a loki because
obviously
we're kind of it's not like disney is
gonna take this show that needs to be so
universal for people who aren't super
super deep into the comics
so i don't think that they're going to
do like a crazy deep cut that's kind of
why i think that they're going to go
with king loki
but i kind of had a theory um loki used
to kind of be like working
working with thanos to try to get that
angle you know and i was wondering if
maybe he's working in
angle with kang the conqueror because
king the conqueror has
access to all that time travel stuff
he's like an expert at that
and so i'm wondering if loki is like
partnered with him
king loki has partnered with him in some
way and the two of them are gonna end up
being there together
in some capacity working either working
together or loki's tricking him into
working with him
that could still be valid because yeah
loki could trick
could hope to trick king the conqueror
by the end of it yeah exactly
i do you know i really like jessica's
renslayer
theory though like obviously i didn't
know that you could win this
show so obviously i think my my theory
is a little bit better but i like
jessica's because
it would make sense that um that red
slayer would
have a version of herself and like give
her miss minutes
and kind of just like want to benefit
herself put her in control
of the whole thing because she would be
the only person she could trust and when
ren slayer shows up and
sees that she has to like uh face her
maybe she's the one that defeats herself
and she becomes good but that would be a
nice little twist
that no one would see coming so i like
that idea but not better than mine just
for the sake of
not better than mine yours makes the
most sense yours makes the most sense i
think for rogue theory though
um it's it's it's not rogue enough but i
going off of what they said about mine
uh what they said about mine saying that
mine is the best
now that we have eliath there is the
issues where ren slayer does
come back from her own a different
timeline and works together
with earth's red slayer so it's not
impossible
that it could be another red slayer
sitting up in there waiting for this
to come down
it just would be very anti-climactic if
it is run
a different version of rensselaer
sitting there just being like
oh god you made it past goliath also the
fact that she could control eliath would
make no real sense to me unless
this one from a different timeline is
just like using kang's
like ability or doing something but i
don't know also i guess in the series
they don't make goliath kind of like he
is
well he is kind of what he is in the
comics he's invisible and i think much
more powerful
but in this one he's kind of like a
loose cannon dog running all over the
place
so i don't know it just seems like you
couldn't really control him it has to be
someone really powerful in order to
control him
okay i really like that that is a very
rogue theory so for that
i'm going to give you 5 000 rogue
points for that my friend jess
that's a really good theory and of
course i want to hand out points to
everybody else
whitney i'm going to give 4 000 points
for your theory and another 4 000 points
for kale's theory because another loki
does seem very likely
but what do you think is going to be the
big final cliffhanger of the finale like
because we are gonna get a season two of
loki
so like what do you think is going to be
that oh my god i can't wait for season
two moment i think they're gonna kiss
i think they're gonna do a big smooch
it's kid loki
it's kid loki it's gonna be kid loki
he's he's he he he definitely was like
underplayed and yeah he's he's he's got
some sass
i think i think everyone wouldn't mind
seeing kid loki running around
doing loki stuff so and then hopefully
he'd get to keep the alligator and throw
the alligator at people so
everyone gets what they want everyone
gets their alligator they get a kid loki
to put in with the
young avengers kid loki let's just go i
think the
big cliffhanger will be that whoever the
big bad is is going to definitely escape
and there is just going to be turmoil in
the future and we're going to have to
figure out who that person is
it's either going to be that person's
going to escape or which i don't think
will happen but i want to happen from a
writer perspective
i want loki to die and sylvia get away
again you want her to die again i want
him to kick
i want him to kick sylvie through some
portal to save her
because she said she said what if you
betray me and i think that betray's
gonna be in an act of
love and i think he's gonna kick her to
safety and then he's gonna fight and
lose
and he's gonna die and i think he's
gonna die a hero which is gonna be even
worse for the timeline because he's
gonna die a hero again
so oh my god i want that i can't
i can't i can't i can't watch loki die
again it's just like
if i had to watch a vision die if i had
to watch vision die eight times
you guys can deal with loki dying like
20. i
no i know my man died so many times for
this franchise
what do you think whitney um well i do
think that
i'm not 100 sure on really
anything
but uh i do think that if it is
something with kang the conqueror or
whatever it is it's just gonna be
setting up for quantum mania
whatever it is and i also think that
loki and sylvie are gonna smooch
and i want them to and i don't care if
it's weird to kiss yourself i think it's
great
i want them to kiss so bad that's my
cliffhanger
i want them to just be like smooching
hey it's self-love yeah it's so
self-love i agree what are they gonna
smooch before
because they've had so many good smooch
moments what do you think is going to be
the smooch
they're going to smooch and get kicked
through the portal they're going to get
smooched and kicked through the corner
smooch and then death oh my god the old
smooching kick
the old smooching kick to the portal it
worked in 300 it can work here
did he kiss him before he kicked him in
300 and and in my dreams
he's like this is sparta
kisses his forehead and then just kicks
them straight in the chest gentle gentle
gentle kiss
yes yes oh man a rated g300 i want to
see that
um okay so that is it for that question
thank you guys for your
amazing answers so we got some more
theories about all those glorious easter
eggs hidden throughout this episode but
first
a few words from the folks that help us
make rogue theory so
are you currently shirtless and need
something to cover your shivering body
well we can help at new rockstars merch
we have all kinds of shirts including
this limited edition
latest obsession shirt loki out of time
which i'm wearing right now it's my most
prized possession
i won't let it out of my sight i haven't
showered in many weeks
buying the latest obsession shirt will
give you the ability to leave a message
on our inside marvel
loki after show that will show up on
screen during the show which is pretty
cool
and we got a full line of loki inspired
merch including stickers buttons
and ties though act fast because some of
these items and sizes are selling out
like really fast so find it all over
at newrockstarsmerch.com but of course
we want to thank upstart for sponsoring
this video if you dread looking at your
credit card statements you're not alone
debt can feel crippling but upstart
can help you on your path to financial
freedom upstart is a fast and easy way
to pay off your debt with a personal
loan
all online and whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses
over half a million people have used
upstart to get one fixed monthly payment
and upstart knows you're more than just
your credit score and
is expanding access to affordable credit
and unlike other lenders upstart
considers your income and current
employment
to find you a smarter rate for your loan
with a five-minute online rate check you
can see your rate up front for loans
between one thousand to fifty thousand
dollars
you can receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
to find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
rogue that's upstart.com rogue and don't
forget to use our url to let them know
that we
sent you loan amounts will be determined
based on your credit income and certain
other information provided in your loan
application
go to upstart.com our friends at bluechu
have a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in doable form and
at a fraction of the cost
bluetooth is an online prescription
service so no doctor's office or
pharmacy trips and it ships right to
your door in a discreet
package you sign up at bluetooth.com
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved you receive your prescription
within days
and their licensed medical providers
work with you to find the right
ingredient and strength and if you hate
swallowing pills
good news blue chew is chewable just
like it says in the name so if you can
benefit from some extra confidence when
it's time to perform in the bed
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information
and we've got a special offer for our
audience try blue chew free when you use
our promo code
rogue at checkout and just pay five
dollars in shipping that's bluetooth.com
promo code rogue to receive your first
month for free and we thank bluechu
for sponsoring this video and of course
we want to thank betterhall for
sponsoring this video as well is there
something interfering with your
happiness preventing you from achieving
your goals like i personally struggle
from depression hardcore if i have for
the longest time so like
i know that like a therapist is a really
huge help betterhelp will assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours it's not a crisis line
it's not self-help it's professional
counseling done securely online and the
service is available for clients
worldwide and has a broad range of
expertise available which may not be
focally available in many areas so log
in to your account anytime and send a
message to your counselor and you'll get
timely and thoughtful responses plus you
can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions better help is committed to
facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
needed and it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available betterhelp
wants you to start living a happier life
today so visit betterhelp.com
rogue that's better h-e-l-p and join
over 1 million people
who have taken charge of their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional and there's a special offer
for the rogue theory audience get up to
off your first month at betterhelp.com
rogue all right gang let's talk some
more
loki so the void is scattered with
marvel easter eggs including throg
the thanos copter the dark aster ship a
project inside hella carrier
kang tower and classic loki confirming
the fan theory
that loki faked his death disguising
himself as floating debris so which of
these
do you think is most likely to be
restored as mcu cannon and pitch the
story
behind this pruned detail uh though i'll
be honest the one i really would like to
see out of all of these is classic
loki's tail
but i just don't think it's gonna need
to come back as much as kid loki's will
and i like the idea that kid loki claims
that he killed thor in this episode so
he claims that he killed thor
but also these are people that got
pruned from their timeline because and i
think he said it or someone said it they
were trying to change themselves they
were trying to better themselves
so i feel like it could have been even
like a ragnarok scenario
where like he uh like tried saving
thorin thor died
or he tried to jump in a way and thor
died by accident instead of him
or honestly just like it
it had to be something by accident that
he's honestly just weighing on himself
he's a child right
so he's probably just saying that he's
the reason thor died he killed thor
and people probably acknowledge him as
the person that killed thor because he
is just loki
but the tva is like but deep down
you know you're the hero and we can't
have that so that's why they pruned him
um and then that way he's just like even
as like a young avenger or wherever he's
coming back
he'll always be guilted with that
scenario of like
i killed my brother i killed thor
and people are like but did you kill
thor did you just
it was an accident like calm down dude
you need to relax
um so i think we're gonna see kid loki
more so but i would love to see classic
loki's tail
oh my god okay i would kill for that
okay i like that what about you whitney
what you got what do you got whitney
okay well first of all just while we're
just really quick while we're on the
subject of kid loki
i love that they have high c in juice
boxes in the void
because that was the best part they were
all slug and wine and then he was just
was it ecto cooler dude i hope it was
active i didn't zoom in but ecto cooler
was my favorite flavor
i think it was ecto cooler god i hope so
ecto cooler in the void makes sense
because obviously it was a limited
edition thing so maybe in this timeline
yeah we
still have ecto cooling it was a varied
yeah god damn it i wish i was surge in
there too
amazing i would do anything to get an
echo cooler
any flavor that gets discontinued gets
sent to the void so
oh absolutely tostadas from taco bell
are in the void yeah
the szechuan
[Laughter]
sometimes but it leaves like when it
comes back every once in a while
oh it keeps coming back yeah yeah it
keeps coming it finds one of the little
time pads
every time again yes the mcrib has a
temp ad that is exactly what happened
something that i think that i'm
definitely interested in
seeing the canon behind is uh
mobius's character because i really want
to know like what his nexus event was
i want to see if he ever gets his jet
ski and i
do have a pretty rogue theory about uh
what mobius's
nexus could be and that's something that
i might want to see
um i my my friend john piracello and i
were talking and he was saying that he
believes
that uh mobius is actually a variant of
real-life actor owen wilson
he was not he was not allowed to say he
was not allowed to say wow
in this show they told him no wow and so
on a different timeline he did say wow
in the show
so he immediately had to be pruned and
that's how he became mobius
oh wow now that's a rogue theory wow
wow that's what i believe um and also my
french hellos believes that so we're
we're stuck on that theory
we're stuck on it okay real life all
right owen wilson
writing that down owen wilson
i that is a very rogue theory to knock
on
mt's door ding ding dong dong
so i think for sure you are right about
loki being a damn
like moby is being a damn variant of
loki because that scene where he zoomed
they zoomed into all six of their eyes
and alligator loki was the only one with
yellow eyes
they can't have yellow eyes well they
could but the fact is like
they all had the exact identical eye and
i was like
this son of a i was like this son
of a he is alone
mobius is totally he's a location like
that on his eyes
he's straight up they literally did cast
in and was like blue eyed
men only yeah i was like they all have
the exact same eyes i was like
and they zoomed in on all of their faces
and i was like they all look the same
except for you know alligator loki
because he's an animal but
dude i really want alligator loki to
just have sparkling baby blues
i would love that dude if mobius turns
out to be a loki loki is definitely
gonna try and have sex with him it's
it's definitely
[Music]
yeah that's going to be my new threesome
favorite is loki
a classic loki all for me
classically that's a new blunt rotation
as you pick which loki's you'd wanna
first
i'm sorry i just want to kiss his little
face i'm waiting for those plushes
i'm waiting for those plushies to come
out me too and i'm going to buy like 10.
they need to make pet horns yeah and
then you could just put it on whatever
pet you have
oh they should they should make the horn
you could put on your pug whitney
i definitely want a pugsley loki a
pugsley loki would be
top yes oh my god
does marvel watch this show okay well
owen i know i know you're a variant owen
okay so we heard from whitney we're from
jess
what do you think kale well they already
took some really good they took the
better theories where we see
uh we we see the older loki floating
around as
as trash in the universe for a long long
time that's
that's a good one and just like me yeah
yeah
and then and then young loki but i
am such a thanos stan that i just want
to see thanos come back in some form
and since we saw the thanos copter and
since it's still
disney yeah i think we should get a
thanos copter
in cars yes i think she'll come back
in cars as thanos copter oh my god
because we haven't seen a cars movie in
a while so i think the cars need
they need a villain so and you know they
they can dress up as you know
carpet and americart in america or black
window
you know like there's many different
black tint black tint
that is hilarious but yeah i'd love to
see the cars and then and owen wilson's
in that too
so there it is yeah he's a lightning
mcqueen so there you go
i think you have solved this whole thing
kale yeah yeah absolutely
thanos copter okay so the car's universe
i'm gonna write that down
theory this is rogue theory and i'm just
saying he's a rogue ass
we are going mega rogue so we have we
have cars we got real life on wilson and
we got a kid loki theory i'ma go ahead
and reward these points now
and i'm gonna have to give that cars
theory
yes a whole 5 000 because that is crazy
but i'm also
going to give real life owen wilson a
whole five thousand
crazy wow wow and i'm gonna give kid
loki a 4 000. because it is pretty good
but like oh wow oh wow because it is
pretty good but i don't think it's as
crazy as a cars or a real life on wilson
ah this is rogue theory at the end of
the day this is
the end of the day we gotta go rope so
we got okay so we got five thousand for
kale and then we got five thousand four
and we gotta keep track here five
thousand for whitney
look you're the banker and monopoly but
you're the bad part
the bad one this is my second time
hosting okay
okay i'm still going okay i'm just
saying you better
let me some extra points if you slip in
any
extra points it better be me okay okay
so let us move on to our rogue question
today's real question of the day
is with netflix rebooting the beloved
he-man and the master of the universe
which favorite cartoon show from your
childhood would you like to see
redone today um
i want i want clone high back i i don't
care what don't hide
i need it back everyone that likes clone
high everyone that watched it
loved it it's it's by chris miller and
phil lord
like they're hot right now why not bring
it back the cast is great
was it isn't it coming back i thought i
heard something of it coming back listen
i'll believe it when i see it you know
how many times i've heard that the
uncharted movie was being made
i've heard that that's being since it's
almost done i know i know
i i understand it i hear you but i've
been reporting on that since i've been
doing entertainment news
over a decade so when i see it on the
big screen
tom holland could do he could sit there
and he could just the whole movie it
could be him staring at the screen being
like i hate you kale but as long as it
was made
i i'll i'll believe it but so when we
see clone high
i'll believe it but i would love to see
that true everyone if you haven't
watched clone height
watch it it's it became a meme with the
the jfk stuff yeah it's great great show
great show it's a really great i think
it would be super intense and dark
and cool if they did a live action
gargoyles
oh
so sick and then like so many kids that
don't know gargoyles would be so into it
because they'd be like
what the hell's a gargoyle i'd be like
what the hell
i never seen
that's why i say to my nephew and he'll
be like okay auntie calm down
gargoyles just gargoyles um but
like
yeah i would while out if they made like
a live-action dark
cd like gargoyle like that'd be scary i
love it
i i would freaking love that what about
you whitney all right
uh i gotta go always with
uh i want more invader zim enter the
florpis wasn't enough for me
i was obsessed with it i've watched i've
i've watched
enter the floorpiece probably like 800
times the part where he like throws the
pug
into the sky i'm just that cracks me up
every single time
just like it just being like but i love
that pig you know
uh so i would i really want more
invaders in and
i wish that i could force jonah vazquez
to give me more because it's all i want
i mean we can we just all leave right
now let's force him to do it
he can't stop all of us get in the car
let's
go down to his house if you harass him
on twitter enough he'll do it
that's the general rule for anything
really we'll take a bunch of those
gummies and then we'll head out
okay we got invaders in we got gargoyles
and we got
clone high but i know i love me some
gargoyles that's a really good answer
i'm sorry and then i'm gonna give five
thousand for invaders them and i'm gonna
give
six thousand four clone high because
that's a big cut clone height is a deep
ass cut
one has a deep cut you know what's great
about the gargoyles too is you could
like if you're you know you had kids you
would just be like
oh everyone you're a gargoyle now if you
want them to just like stop being
rambunctious and then they all just
freeze and stuff
great way to just stop them from being
we have a bunch of creepy children that
think they're
going to just stand in a supermarket i'm
like gargoyle now
no that's exactly next to the pepsi just
like people were like
are they okay i'm like yeah they just
saw the movie gargoyles they're just
gargoyles
right up against the deli counter it's
the new planking it's just
gargoyling
a menace menace to society truly should
never happen
we ruined it it was a great idea no it's
not
well i think this makes jess our winner
for today's
theory congratulations yo kale play the
play the
play the clap thing do it
now it's official we did it
congratulations jess you're amazing as
always but now
it is now proven that you are the rogue
theory princess
of the day wish i was a rope theory
princess
too late he already gave me the title he
already gave me the title
i am the princess but that is it for
this episode of rogue theory thank you
to our guest whitney van laningham
kale anonymous and jessica clemens you
can follow them on twitter
and of course you can support our
channel by checking out our new loki
theme merch
like this it's pretty oh lift it higher
lift it higher
it's the latest obsession shirt it's
awesome it's really cool
you should go get it because it's
running out of time it's not going to be
here forever
you go to new rockstarsmerch.com again
be like me
okay you can follow me at mastertainment
if you want to see me tweet some really
weird
pointless but most importantly
follow new rock stars wherever we are
and subscribe here on youtube and we
will see you guys next time don't follow
mt he's going to retweet how you look
like a cabbage patch doll
what he's going to say that you love
he's funny
[Music]
i wish i could show it to the camera
right now but i do not look like that
damn doll
you're the one who tweeted the
comparison you're watching
oh my god i didn't agree i just
retweeted it i was
like hey let's see what people think
what good night i didn't say nothing
okay
pretty much this is the part of the
sitcom where i get food
[Music]
you